stated and the president has essentially
set himself at war against the rule of
law in saying that when we talk about
the difference between a democracy and a
dictatorship one of the foundational
principles of our Constitution is that
of checks and balances which means that
co-equal branches of government have to
respond to each other and so with the
president's blanket refusal to honor
subpoenas to allow witnesses to testify
he has taken this to a completely new
phase and I think as I watched attorney
general bars performance yesterday in
the Senate there were so many questions
that continue to arise about whether the
Attorney General is using his position
to be the personal counsel for personal
defense counsel for the president my
line of questioning today had I had the
opportunity would have been around
ongoing attempts at obstruction of
justice this is not just something that
is in the past but the president is
continuing to tweet and say things that
imply that if somebody refuses to tell
the truth or speaks against him that
there will be consequences to pay there
are numerous things that we have a
responsibility and an obligation to
investigate and to oversee and I think
we are truly in a new phase of this
entire situation that is deeply deeply
destructive to the Constitution and to
the foundations of our democracy
I think what the House Judiciary
Committee and my colleagues and chairman
Nadler did today was to do something
that the American people have not seen
since the Watergate proceedings of
Richard Nixon they have not seen a
president not stand up to the Congress
but stand up to the Constitution in a
way that rejects all of its parameters
and all of the dignity and the order
that we have run this country the
Constitution started out by saying we
wanted to form a more perfect union
today the Attorney General joined with
his supervisor the president United
States decided to show the American
people that this is not a democracy that
in fact we do not adhere to the rule of
law and we will continue to be
disrespectful to the people's house I
think my line of questioning as my
colleagues have indicated would be just
the truth as the March 27th Mullett
letter stated to the Attorney General
that he wanted the documents to be
released they were not released and so
here we stand today with no other
options other than to hold the Attorney
General in contempt which we hope that
will happen we have not done that
because we wanted to continue
negotiations so I would simply ask the
question is this the way we want to run
this nation do we want a president that
does not welcome the truth and
subjecting those who work for him to be
tested on the truth do we not understand
the Constitution and article 1 and
article 2 this Judiciary Committee will
not be targeting anyone all will be
doing is doing our job and that is to
have members of the cabinet of the
President of the United States to come
before this committee and tell the truth
we will not stop until we get the truth
on until the truth is told to the
American people and the American people
will decide as we go forward that the
truth has to be acted on and that's what
I think some of our Republican friends
are afraid of
attorney general bill Barr is not one of
the most dangerous men in Washington DC
for three reasons first he intentionally
mischaracterize the mullah report he was
then told by Robert Moldova he
mischaracterize him all the report and
instead of apologizing he doubles down
and continues mislead American people
second today he ignored the will of
Congress over some responsibilities of
Congress and lawfully issued subpoenas
and third right now he is suing to
eliminate your health care coverage
let's not forget right now he is suing
in court to eliminate pre-existing
conditions health care coverage and
taking health care coverage away from
millions of Americans we in Congress
will rein him in we will hold him
accountable
as a first-time member of Congress I
can't imagine any place else I would
rather be right now I mean as a student
of American history as a supporter of
our Constitution this is just such a
grave moment and I hope everyone is
understanding how grave it is
particularly those at the White House
thank you good morning everyone
you know I just have to say as a former
police chief that it was painful and
disgraceful to see the nation's top cop
abandon his responsibilities to allow an
empty chair to speak for him this
morning however as a committee member we
were respectful enough to put the
Honorable William P bar to put honorable
on his name tag if you will this morning
however but if you look at what the
Attorney General has done since he has
been in office he certainly worked
harder to protect someone who does not
deserve to be protected there's not much
that the Attorney General has done as
the nation's top cop that we can
consider honorable and so this morning
was a dark day of dark mourning for the
United States of America and all that
the Department of Justice should mean to
this nation so thank you
in the 2016 elections this nation was
attacked from outside of its borders by
the Russians as a result of their
outside attack we are now being attacked
from the inside by the very Trump
administration whom the Russians favored
this is a very dark day and a very dark
time for our Republic it is under attack
the worst kind of damage that can be
done to America is from its enemies from
within and we have enemies and we have
aiders and abetters of those imminent
enemies I'm afraid that we have reached
a time when the people of this great
nation must stand up and demand that
Congress take appropriate action to stop
this attack on our Republic and save
this nation it's democracy and all of
the ideals of Liberty fairness and
justice that we all hold dear thank you
I've been a student of government all my
life
I watched the Watergate hearings from
the beginning to the end this smacks so
much of Watergate an attorney general
like John Mitchell who believes the
president is above the law that is not
America the president is not above the
law and if the president thinks that
special counsels investigation is a
witch-hunt he cannot stop it
but our Attorney General thinks so
chicken bar should have shown up today
and answered questions he was afraid of
Barry Burke he was afraid of norm Ison a
tourney general who's picked for his
legal acumen and his abilities would not
be fearful of any other attorneys
questioning him for 30 minutes
this man was picked to be Roy Cohn and
to be Donald Trump's fixer the black
socks looked clean compared to this team
it's a sad day in America good morning I
did not have the privilege of being born
into this country I became an American
citizen when I was 20 years old and I
took an oath to protect and defend the
Constitution against all foreign and
domestic enemies Attorney General Barr
took the same oath and today he shows
that the only oath that he is now
following is to protect and defend the
president who right now is threatening
the strength of our democracy having
come from Latin America I understand
very well what it means when a man in
power starts circumventing equal
branches of government we must not allow
this to happen in the United States of
America thank you
at the morning the Attorney General has
a constitutional responsibility to
uphold the rule of law instead he's done
everything to undermine the rule of law
the so called Attorney General is
abrasive evasive and unpersuasive he is
a disgrace to the office that he
currently holds the so-called Attorney
General is missing in action absent
without official leave and has clearly
made the decision to serve as the
personal fixer for Donald Trump
inconsistent with the oath of office
that he has taken and we as House
Democrats recognize that we are a
separate and co-equal branch of
government we don't work for Donald
Trump we work for the American people we
have a constitutional responsibility to
serve as a check and balance on an
out-of-control executive branch Donald
Trump the so-called Attorney General and
his minions are out of control right now
we won't overreach we won't have a
politicize we won't over investigate but
we will do our constitutional oversight
responsibilities the so-called attorney
general can run but he cannot hide
today Attorney General bar and this
administration have done a great
disservice to the American people it's
not only about the Muller report but
this is about protecting the integrity
of our national security this is about
protecting the integrity of our
elections this is about protecting the
integrity of people in this country
being able to have affordable health
care they have done a great disservice
to the American people and we Congress
have the responsibility as a co-equal
branch of government to protect and to
serve and make sure the American people
have the facts and the information that
they need to make sure that they know
that government is truly working on
their behalf and my colleagues and I
will continue to stand to fight for the
truth continue to stand for what is
right to make sure that democracy works
for each and every individual in this
country - Ted today we will still
continue to stand to wait for the truth
because you deserve it
well I think I mean I I think the
members I think we all believe very
strongly that the next step is to begin
proceedings to hold the Attorney General
in contempt for the failure to comply
with the subpoena yesterday I think we
are all pressing our Chairman to do that
he's as he has been attempting to
negotiate in good faith to see if the
attorney I will do it voluntarily but in
the absence of agreement there it is our
position that the the Attorney General
is in contempt of Congress that we have
a responsibility to compel his
compliance with a lawfully issued
subpoena because as I said earlier if
the executive branch can wilfully
violate lawfully issued subpoenas they
will have successfully eliminated
congressional oversight it cannot be up
to the executive branch to decide what
witnesses and what evidence we will
collect in our Constitution mandated
oversight responsibilities so the next
step will be an effort to begin
proceedings to hold the Attorney General
in contempt if in fact this negotiation
or conversation doesn't result in an
agreement I think we all feel
no but I well at this point I think
there's also a question of what the
Attorney General is can continue to say
and do he did not show in the Senate
hearings yesterday that he was going to
answer some of the very difficult
questions in fact he made it clear on
several occasions that he thought that
it was fine for the president to lie for
the president to say things to people
and encourage them to not tell the truth
so at this point another step that we
will be taking and that the chairman has
already put into place is we want robert
muller to come and testify before us at
this point i think we need to hear
directly from the special counsel about
his report and about his findings
clearly he felt troubled enough by what
attorney general barr did and said that
he wrote not one but two letters to the
Attorney General
he even prepared summaries of his two
volumes that could be released
immediately to the American people and
yet we did not see that happen it was
almost thirty two days I think from the
time that he delivered his report to
yesterday when we learned that he had
these summaries prepared and ready to go
to the public so at this point I think
in addition to holding the Attorney
General in contempt should these
negotiations not work out we need to
have Robert Muller
at this point I don't feel that I can
trust anything that the Attorney General
is saying because I don't know who the
Attorney General works for he certainly
is not working for the American people
well there is first of all the one thing
I'd like to say is Democrats are not
rushing toward impeachment but neither
are we afraid of it the format that
we're using is a format to be able to
educate the Congress and the American
people about how much untruth has been
said these are dangerous times because
if we set the precedent as general Barr
has done who is next not to respond to
the Congress
what cabinet officer in the midst of a
crisis is the acting Department of
Homeland Security secretary in the midst
of a crisis isn't the Health and Human
Services so one of the things that we
will continue to do is use possibly the
contempt proceeding as our Chairman may
decide to do in addition we will not
take off an ultimate act that we are
allowed to do under the Constitution but
let me show you the example when the
tapes were found would Richard Nixon the
American people said enough is enough I
can assure you as we build the blocks of
finding out the truth there is still of
that proceeding but we will not be
baited into it as our friends in the
committee choose to try and do we will
only do it as this Constitution gives us
the power to do so we're not intimidated
by the fact that it may be a little
longer the idea of the attorneys as many
have seen is the continuity of
questioning that means that you can
cross-examine in the midst of your time
frame collectively the excellent members
of Congress that are on this committee I
have been stunned and excited by their
questioning and their thoughts we will
put all that together but what happens
when the lawyers and I have been on
impeachment proceedings in this
committee judges and others is the line
of reasoning that allows even the
American people to see the building
blocks and the
story narrative of truth that is so very
important well I will just say this our
Committee Chairman is very patient but
he's very knowledgeable and he
understands the timeframe let me say
this let's hope that there is something
productive over the weekend let's hope
that the general of the United States
understands his duty and as my
colleagues have said will pay and affirm
allegiance to the flag of the United
States of America and not a single man
who is fleeting in that job so we're
hoping that general bars own credibility
in love of this country
oh the weekend will generate a
resolution of this but the house rules
permit this kind of question we approved
it in a motion before the committee it's
done it has been done many other times
most recently with dr. Blasi ford so you
the real question is not why do we want
to collect evidence in this way the real
question is to the Attorney General
what are you afraid of why don't you
want to be questioned in a half hour
feared by a staff attorney that's the
real question for the American people
and for the media front but to your
previous point are you are you concerned
that this is now going to get bought to
your previous point are you concerned
that this is now just going to get
bogged down in court and are you all
okay with the fact that it Matt may now
take longer for you to get all of these
answers that you're demanding so let's
just walk through the process of how
contemporary seedings work so a church
of Dale bar has violated a lawful
subpoena to provide us the full model
report its underlying evidence if we go
to contempt the House Judicial Committee
will vote if we vote it out it goes the
House floor once the House floor votes
it out then it triggers a number of
things or House Counsel can go litigate
in court but we also have inherent
content powers that courts have upheld
for us to take immediate action
irrespective of the courts we can start
imposing fines
that person in the past they had a house
jail
I don't think we'll go that far but
courts have upheld that as well so
Congress's power will not be abdicated
we will enforce it and the delay will
not affect us because we can start
imposing fines on that person
immediately upon content off the House
floor and we will go there if he does
not cooperate but that's still a very
long time before you get any of the
answers that you were hoping to get here
today that's just a matter of weeks to
get something off a House floor what
would it take to move to impeach bill
Barr is that's something that's on the
table and what what would it take for
you to take that drastic step do you
think we'll respect to the Attorney
General's behavior nothing's on the
table or off the table we're evaluating
things in a step-by-step basis and the
next step as has been Illustrated will
be to possibly pursue contempt and
Congress has control over that timeline
but understand the stakes what we are
witnessing is the slow loss of our
democratic republic and we can either
allow it to happen or we can stand up
against it some of my colleagues on the
other side of the aisle they're behaving
like a cover-up caucus for this
president a wholly owned subsidiary of
the Trump administration that is not
what the founding fathers envisioned and
so we are not going to allow the notion
of a presidential dictatorship to take
hold this is a democracy we're separate
and co-equal branch of government and we
are going to uphold that principle by
any means necessary
you were talked about how staffing goes
steering hey now are you quitting this
you wanted to know I think my colleague
just indicated that this process was
used during the cabin our hearings and
what we're saying is that this is the
point that we're making that this is
this is allowable under house rules the
Congress as the Senate and the House and
the Senate can discern and decide their
own rules and the best approach to draw
evidence or information so that we can
make the appropriate decision let me
also say we're writing legislation
regarding what happened in volume 1 and
volume 2 how incredulous is it of all of
the contacts with Russians that there
was no legal basis other than pollution
or conspiracy why wasn't there the
interacting with Russian operatives
enemies of the American people and that
that would be a criminal act which we're
introducing legislation on that or have
already done so but what I would say to
you is we're only following the rules
and the rules are that we're allowed to
do this and I guess I asked the question
of the general of the United States has
been said very aptly and my heart really
breaks on this if any of us were lawyers
or non lawyers it really breaks I asked
him would he not in his view of his own
reputation and his view of being the
chief legal officer has been said for
the people of the United States would he
should I say that would he please adhere
to the rule of law and appear before
this committee but I do want to conclude
by saying we're moving on other
witnesses because our chances to find
out the truth why didn't you take the
Justice Department's the opportunity
they provided to you to go and see a
lesser lesser redacted copy of the
report
my understanding is only
but Democrats refused to do so he was
not given to us let's let's refocus on
what's at stake here okay six weeks
after the special counsel submitted his
report the Congress the United States
still doesn't have it this is completely
unprecedented in every other case of his
special counsel were an Independent
Counsel report Congress got it within a
couple of days completely unredacted the
reductions are up to us and special
counsel Muller gave the redactions
directly to attorney general Barr that's
what we've learned in the last couple of
days from new correspondents which was
leaked through the media that was the
only reason we found out about it it was
very clear that the report could have
been released within a couple of days
but instead Attorney General Barr wanted
to pull a propaganda smokescreen over
the entire country and we are still
laboring to unearth the real report to
get it unredacted so we can read it that
is our constitutional power and my
colleagues keep saying we are a co-equal
branch of government we are at least a
co-equal branch of government we are
article one before article 2 we are the
law making power of the American people
we are the direct representative
American people and the president's job
is just to take care that the laws are
faithfully executed not to make sure
that the laws are thwarted and
frustrated and violated and yet the
entire administration is now in a
full-blown cover-up mode to try to hide
the contents of special counsel Muller's
report and all that Attorney General did
the Attorney General farted was to try
to tell a false story to the American
people about what was in there and they
continued to scramble to throw out more
and more propaganda to cover up what's
really in there we are going to get to
the bottom of this we are going to have
the real facts come out to the American
people we are going to allow the
American people to hear directly from
the witnesses including special counsel
Muller including Don McCain the White
House Counsel about what the president
did to obstruct justice
because if we allow a president
to obstruct justice and to convert the
government of the United States into a
money-making vehicle for himself and his
family and his business then that will
set a precedent that generations to come
will regret and lament we've got a
constitutional responsibility here and
we're gonna fulfill it I just want to
say one thing about director Mullen I
was here when he was director of the FBI
and I was offended by his character and
integrity being sullied yesterday in the
Senate Judiciary hearing I want to thank
director Muller for his work and his
team's work I don't know what he's going
to say before our committee I cannot
prognosis give a prognosis on what he
will say but I do believe the American
people owe him a debt of gratitude and I
also know that it has been reported by
people who know him they've said he has
never sent a letter maybe once a letter
of this time in his career he wants to
be known as an ex-marine
who serves his nation and so I would
just suggest to all of us that if he
wrote such a letter on March 27th when
he said in essence I told you to give
everything to the Congress and the
American people it must have been a
heavy burden on him that the general of
the United States the Attorney General
was not representing him his team are
the people of the United States that in
fact he turned out to be the personal
lawyer of a person who was fleeting in
an office that belongs to the people of
the United States and that's the
presidency and I can only say that as he
comes before our committee none of us
can dictate what he will say but I do
believe that he will tell the truth in
the best way he possibly can and I want
to say to director Muller thank you very
much for your service thank you
if good-faith negotiations don't result
in a pledge of compliance in the next
day or two the next step is seeking a
Content citation against the Attorney
General committee will convene at nine
o'clock tomorrow morning as planned my
colleagues will be present I hope and
expect that the Attorney General will
think overnight and will be there as
well
[Music]
the failure of Attorney General bar to
come to the hearing today is simply
another step in the administration's
growing attack on American democracy and
its attack on the right of Congress to
be a coordinate branch of government and
to have the information it needs to
legislate and act on behalf of the
American people the administration by
its policy of across the board across
the board defiance of congressional
subpoenas and the bhim is saying that
only the executive matters that we don't
need we don't want limitations by
Congress that the Constitution imposes
on us this is a grave danger for
American democracy and we must do all we
can in the name of the American people
to ensure that when the Trump
administration ends we have as robust a
democracy to hand to our children as we
hit which was handed to us and today is
a day of testing and everyone will be
judged by history by in terms of how
they react to this mr. chairman how
concerned are you that this is all just
going to get bogged down in the courts
and that because of your insistence on
letting staff attorneys do some
questioning that it will now take even
longer for you to get the answers that
you've been demanding we are going to
use what what process we have in the
courts and elsewhere to get the answers
in the information we need in particular
the subpoena for the UM for the entire
unredacted model report and the
underlying documents was due yesterday
the Attorney General we got a letter
late last night refusing us refusing to
adhere to the subpoena this is
indefensible and it is part of the
attack on American democracy by this
administration we will make one more
good-faith attempt to negotiate and to
get the to get the access to the report
that we need and then and then if we
don't get that we will proceed to hold
the
general in contempt and we'll go from
there day or two maybe by Monday we'll
see we cannot concede to the
administration the ability to control
the manner in which Congress does its
job the Attorney General is bound as our
other witnesses to come before the
committee and then he cannot dictate to
us how we will do our job we feel this
is the most effective way of doing it
and that's our decision
we will explore all the options and
inherent contempt is certainly one of
the options the administration the
Attorney General apparently is afraid of
proper cross examination we ask
questions under the five-minute rule and
we've seen a pattern from this
administration the administration
witnesses filibustered for four and a
half minutes and then give a
non-responsive answer for the next fight
for the next half a minute and then it's
on to a different question who may have
other questions in mind or may not
properly follow-up the way a good cross
examiner would so we feel the best way
of doing this is to have all our members
ask their five minutes of questions each
and have counsel be able to clean to bat
cleanup so to speak at the end follow
loose ends and be able to hold it to the
witness the attorney general in this
case to ask follow-up questions so that
he can't evade as easily as you can and
obviously the Attorney General is afraid
to face that kind of questioning I mean
what we saw today is besides the
attitude of contempt the administration
as for Congress what we saw is fear fear
of the fective course examination period
[Music]